I love this story and I actually want
you to share it for people who may not
know how all of this happened yeah so my
best friend she's the one who sent me
that tweet because I wasn't even
following Mindy or you know her on
Twitter I wasn't following her on
Instagram
either ones that she put it out on but
my best friend did and she sent it to me
and was like hey like we should do this
and at the time I was going through a
pretty rough patch like in high school
and I just didn't want to get out but
like I love my best friend to death so I
was like you know what homie okay let's
let's do this why not and then we did it
we went to the library I brought my
mom's camera after an hour of figuring
out how to record on a camera and how to
set up the tripod we were rolling we
would do our flying yeah real quick and
then we just sent it in is anyone there
how heights is she now I mean what are
your conversations like I can only
imagine um I think our last conversation
right now was talking about Brooklyn
nine-nine versus good place vs. Parks
and Rec versus the office so nothing
much is chapping like of course like you
know she's super hype um maybe like a
week ago she sent me a video of her with
her laptop open to never have I ever
she's lip-synching all of the lines not
just Davies but Ben's and principal
Grubbs as well and I'm like what are you
doing she's like it's so good I love
this scene first of all can we have the
best can everybody have a best friend
like I love my best friend to death
honestly I loved your caption my best
wood stuck with me the most and you said
some people might think is jealousy
going on no none of that here and I was
like wow everybody doesn't have an
opportunity to have a friend like that
so girl you're lucky not an a single
ounce of her has been jealous of me it's
like we both won together so that
putting that to people's face when they
asked like oh she auditioned too because
she did but when people like asked I
made like sort of push that maybe she's
jealous now or and
I'm like you don't know how we roll has
it set in for you that you're actually a
role model like you're legit role model
for young girls who have never seen
someone who looks like them on TV that's
you how does that go it's crazy
honestly it's really crazy because like
it's over dude the representation to
have like South Asian role models and
you know of course sure we have some but
definitely not enough right because I'm
only the role model for a certain
handful of South Asian girls out there
who can relate to my experience right
but we need more to come and like Mindy
paved the way for me to be able to break
into Hollywood I hope one day I'm in the
position in my career where I can do the
same and bring other South Asians to the
light of Hollywood and have their moment
to shine and tell their stories and you
know bring their unique voice to scream
you mentioned Mindy you call her your
fairy godmother that's something that
she's taught you that you're gonna take
with you for the rest of your life
definitely no matter what it is whether
it's my acting career or just living my
day-to-day life she always told me to be
myself her and Lancashire both said this
to me when we're at they were telling me
you've made it this far by being
yourself so don't be going off the rails
and imitating somebody else and they
were like if we catch you with cocaine
like I swear to god we'll come down but
in all seriousness stay authentic stay
you because you you nailed it just by
being you keep doing that obviously like
acting is a whole other thing right
character I portray Davey is not me but
Who I am in the industry just how I hold
myself as my tree that's me you've been
very outspoken about the pronunciation
of pronouncing people's names correctly
especially South Asian names which I
really respect and your opinion what is
the best way just to school people here
right now what is the best way to add
some eyes
how to pronounce their name and what is
the best way to correct someone if they
pronounce your name wrong that is a
great question I haven't asked thank you
but I think the best way to ask is just
to be honest and upfront about it don't
wait like the longer you wait it it just
makes it worse because it's like wait
did you not know all this time what's
right right
so just be honest don't be defensive
about it it's all okay we all make
mistakes it's fine and I think people
will respect you more if you just say
okay you mind just saying your name
again
I didn't right here you right be honest
about it don't make fun of it it's fine
don't make a big deal of it and the best
way to correct somebody is have that
understanding that people are trying
right you can't expect perfection all
the time and realize hey you know what
it's actually pretty awesome that they
are taking the time to ask and clarify
because we're going forward it'll be
done right that's awesome right cuz it
does take a little boldness to say um no
you didn't say that right April 14th you
tweeted guys an idea a Disney Princess
has naturally South Asian without
stereotypes in a predictable plot line
she's hella street smart sarcastic and
super badass
sounds like you what could be you know
then you followed up with quote I'm
bringing this back up when I get more
clout this is happening you have more
clout now imma need you to retweet this
again I got it
oh I actually speaking about this like
the other day that came like that tweet
came up from a conversation between me
and one of my friends who's Disney
obsessed and she was like yo it's time
to get like a South Asian story right
cuz jasmine is like you know Middle
Eastern but she's not cuz she's not from
a real place but it's also based off you
know a real story so we don't have like
proper like solidified representation
right and when my white Disney create
like crazy fret like friend she's white
and she's like honestly why do I get so
many princesses you get like none what
is this what it's coming
soon cuz you know Mindy has expressed
interest in working with marble or
midmark marble would you have any
interest in being Kamala Khan I know a
lot of people are kind of campaigning
for that online right now the true be
yeah I've seen a couple of us about that
but honestly no because the story of
Kamala Khan
she's Pakistani great focus on II and
I'm thummell if there was a thummell
superhero I wouldn't want to see a
Pakistani girl playing that Europe
because I would stay really so why would
I want to do that to the fun funny
community right you are so awesome it
gives me chills like I'd love to be a
superhero because I love Marvel's so
much okay but like I you know we can
have the Disney Princess why we can have
yeah why do we have to stop it just miss
Marvel you know what
all I'm saying I could be the daughter
of Deadpool we're like The Apprentice or
something I'm just saying like maybe
Deadpool adopts the South Asian girl and
it was like yeah it would make sense we
would make the Canadian joke I mean Ryan
Reynolds we can both yell Canada Oh
[Music]